[Music]
alright well first of all what do you
love most about cardi B I love this she
is who she is and she doesn't trying to
change for nobody and you know when you
don't act like something you're not then
you've got to respect it do you feel
like that's hard to do as a celebrity
like do you struggle with that with
showing a certain side of yourself or
not
no I don't you know and that's what
that's what I love about it because I
can't you know you can always change in
certain ways but you can't change who
you are and I will never act like I'm
something that I'm not and since she
doesn't I love it you know what I love
is I love you and Chloe together what do
you love most about her I mean I don't
really get into the personal things but
just her Mother's Day is coming up do
you have anything special planned for
her course but I'm not gonna tell her on
camera but of course I do know how is
your son doing how old is he now he's
almost 1 are you planning a birthday
party for Nikolas but you're not gonna
get none of the good
I'm trying though right oh you are
you're terrible
alright well thank you so much yes have
a nice night